-Well, guys, this weekend
is the divisional round
of the NFL playoffs
and tomorrow's afternoon game
is Jacksonville Jaguars
facing off
against the Kansas City Chiefs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, as you know, at the end
of every season, they give out
awards like
"most valuable player,"
but they also give out awards
during the playoffs.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show" Superlatives.
-♪ "Tonight Show" Superlatives ♪
-Our first player
is from the Jaguars.
It's their quarterback,
Trevor Lawrence.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Chiefs
is Creed Humphrey.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Chiefs is
Michael Burton.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Anyone need a ride?"
Next up from the Jaguars
is Andrew Wingard.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Chiefs
is Tommy Townsend.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Chiefs
is Noah Gray.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Jaguars
is Brandon Scherff.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
He gets it.
Next up from the Chiefs
is Harrison Buttker.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally,
this is from the Chiefs.
This is Patrick Mahomes.
He was voted...
There you have it.
Those are your Superlatives.